in a world where a lot of competing
different products satisfy the same
requirements you have a lot of
advertisers she want you to try their
product and then you have other
advertisers who want you to try their
product try my product try my product
try my product try No
try my product my products the best no
no no no my products the best try my
product well I want you to forget all
that and try my product forget about
those other advertisers try my product
well there's only one way you can prove
your product is better than the rest and
that's with powerful advertising and one
of the best ways to advertise on the
Internet is via social media and through
the largest social media platform in the
world and that's Facebook so today we're
gonna talk about Facebook Ads tutorial
and I'm excited to teach this class my
name is Rob Sanders I'm with simply
learned and today we are going to talk
about all the different ads that
Facebook has to offer so introduced back
in 2007 the Facebook Ads platform has
grown tremendously over the last few
years almost four billion dollars of
revenue and one year so what does that
mean that means there's a lot of
advertisers why is there's a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a popular platform so not
only is it popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook you have the
opportunity to share your product and
your brand with users who you think are
going to buy your product or associate
with your brand and on Facebook you can
do that a number of different ways
specifically in somebody's newsfeed and
specifically that person's new feed that
again is interested potentially
interested in your brand your product so
there's a lot of ways to advertise and a
lot of reasons why you want to advertise
so I just mentioned one of the reasons
hey it's an opportunity for you to reach
out to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook fact 2.27 billion in
the third quarter of 2018 and so when we
say spend a lot of time we mean going to
that Facebook profile at least once a
day okay so a lot of eyeballs throughout
the day checking their newsfeed on
facebook facebook also enables you the
advertiser to find the perfect audience
and so that's the great combination a
lot of people on Facebook and targeted
audience so it's a platform that allows
you to put your product in front of
people based on specific interest
specific demographics specific location
so you're really really putting your
product out in front of the right people
at the right time and so the other
positive and pro about Facebook is its
lesser spend greater reach what do we
mean by that well traditionally Facebook
is a little bit cheaper than other
online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you in
coorporate your your advertisement and
somebody's newsfeed it's gonna add value
it's gonna establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on Facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on Facebook
active on Facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
Facebook is it also has other features
as our advertising features such as
retargeting so you could target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service or product but if they
didn't go through the conversion process
meaning they didn't go all the way
through and and buy your product and
certainly reach out to them again just
like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
the eight point in time but we can reach
out to them at another point in time and
so Facebook's advertising platform
allows us to do that so it's a great
feature that we could take advantage of
that we'll talk about
more throughout this session and then it
helps increase revenue sales and leads
and that's primarily what most
advertisers are after you know more
revenue more sales more leads so
Facebook allows us to educate our
audience again a target audience about a
specific product we have to offer so the
more our audience knows about our
product especially their friends and
family members and colleagues are using
the product then the more likely they're
going to purchase so if you go back to
the other feature higher revenue less
spend this is the primary reason because
you have a chance to influence somebody
who's very targeted who's very active on
the platform and who may have
like-minded people in their life
associated with your brand and product
so it's a perfect combination for
advertising perfect combination and so
today we're going to talk about all the
different types of Facebook ads and
we're gonna start out with the single
image ad and the single image ad or just
single image
Chai's mints they can have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own Facebook
feed if you look so fact I'll just jump
over to my Facebook feed right now and
if I go there what do I see I see a
single image ad here and it's from
Shopify partners so become a Shopify
partner and add ecommerce to your list
of qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you haven't
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the newsfeed so again I
go back to my newsfeed here you can see
it just really stands out within the
newsfeed so I can't miss it
if I'm a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see this ad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook either that be a
friend or family member is associated
with that product okay in addition to
the single image ads Facebook also has
multi product ads or also known as
carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you in carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different
call-to-action and so here you can see
simply learn has a example of a carousel
ad where they're showcasing their
different courses so this allows users
to view a range of all your different
products and services if you have
multiple products and services to offer
then the carousel ads would be a good
option for you so in addition to the
carousel ads and
it gets a little bit more sophisticated
in terms of Technology where Facebook
allows us to offer up video ads and so
video ads are interactive it's a good
way to really showcase your product your
brand your service and the great thing
about the video ads is they can go from
just a few seconds all the way up to you
know two minutes or excuse me all the
way up to 120 minutes and so you can
really really put a lot of time and
effort into the video ads to really put
your brand out there and so the one
thing about video is it is interactive
most people engage with video and they
tend to get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other forms of ads so the
video ads are really a popular way for
you as an advertiser to put your brand
or product out there so you could put
your brand and product out there and not
just a few seconds but you know really
tell a nice complete story to get the
engagement to get the person to take the
action you want them to do so that's why
video ads have become very popular
because they tend to get more engagement
more interaction than your traditional
single image ad or say your carousel ad
so Facebook also allows us to advertise
something called lead ads and what lead
ads allow us to do is obtain user
details okay so we can acquire or get an
email address or phone number from
somebody who's interested in our product
or service and that person doesn't even
have to leave Facebook so if you look
here in the example here we have the ad
somebody clicks on sign up and they get
this form submission and the great thing
about the lead ad is that it can sync up
with any CRM or most of your popular
serums I should say for example
Salesforce has a good example of a CRM
where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stage right and Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't real
have to leave the platform another form
of advertising on Facebook or slideshows
ok so unlike the carousel ads which
rotate and the carousel ads remember
rotate and showcase different products
or services these ads are interactive
but they're rotating different imagery
so it allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call-to-action just like you see here
with this simply learning example ok so
they're showcasing you know their
different classes and then they have
that get started today call to action a
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called the
collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog ok so if you're an
advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option for you the collection
ad so here you can see the simply learn
example here they're showing you know
not only you know some some good
slideshows and imagery with some good
messaging below that so before we get
into the steps for creating an ad on
Facebook let's talk about some of the
important changes that have happened on
Facebook recently in light of data
sharing so really what Facebook's done
is they've made a important change on
how user data is being used for
advertising and so what Facebook's done
is they remove something called a
partner category and that was an ad
targeting program which the targeting
option was based on data provided by a
third party partner so if you're an
advertiser you had a third party partner
that provided some targeted options to
you that was known as a partner category
and in summary Facebook has removed that
program and so now the only way you can
gain use your information is if they
provide that voluntary like delete add
for example now you have to get the data
directly from the third party now so you
can't have that third party give you
that targeting up option anymore
you can certainly again capture the data
yourself by reliant on leak capture
landing pages as an example or the lead
ads and you can certainly still
outsource your advertising to legion
agencies and media buying companies okay
but the partner category has more or
less gone away okay so now let's get
into how to create a Facebook ad so what
are the steps so the first thing you'll
have to do is set up a campaign so when
you're setting up a campaign you have to
select what kind of spending you want to
do for your advertisement and what you
want to achieve okay so you have to in
other words identify the goal okay so
with Facebook you have two opportunities
at hand here you can jump into an
auction just like Google what you're
going to do is your ads going to enter
into an auction and so this is where you
can decide how you want to spend your
money to achieve your goals by choosing
an appropriate bid strategy for the
auction so in the auction you're
competing with other advertisers another
option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your brand's audience with a fixed cost
so reach and frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility of
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an auction and your auction
is going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so that's the
unpredictability part
is the pricing so pricing can fluctuate
during the auction because you have
different advertisers who are trying to
achieve the most prominence for their ad
with reach and frequency you'll be able
to plan and set up your campaigns and
actually set it up so it's more
predictable on how the delivery is going
to be done with reach and frequency so
more predictability we reach and
frequency because you could set
everything up in your campaign okay so
again with the reach and frequency
you'll be able to advertise with a fixed
cost auction you're not necessarily
going with a fixed cost you're going
with more scalability flexibility on
cost that can change okay so once you
choose your objective for your
advertisement then you need to choose
the type of advertisement you want to do
and it's based on your objectives so
what's your objective is it awareness to
drive awareness is it to drive
consideration or is it to drive a
conversion so these are the three
objectives available to you for your
advertising you want to choose one of
those objectives so let's take a look at
each of these objectives available to
you okay so let's start out with
awareness so awareness can help with
creating an interest for your product or
your service so when we say we're Nisour
thinking maybe brand awareness or
products awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people to think more about our
product and service and have them take
the next step so with awareness you're
introducing your product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step and start looking
for information about the product or
service you're advertising and then
conversion is kind of that final step if
you're really after conversion you
really want that person to make the
decision okay so they're going to buy
or use your product or service and so
that's the conversion objective so you
have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so we
look at brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product in our brand so these types
of objectives I mean meaning awareness
don't really emphasize interaction okay
you're not really trying to get somebody
to purchase or or buy something or
opt-in to a newsletter really your goal
as an advertiser with brand awareness is
to get your product out there so people
are aware that it exists okay let alone
forget about buying it or opting into a
newsletter you really your goal with
awareness and brand awareness is to get
people to see that your existing your
product exists your service exists it's
available and really the aim is to
create high brand recall amongst users
rather than focusing on generating
revenue so when we say you know high
brand recall what we mean is hey if your
brand is out there and you are really
pushing it out there amongst a large
targeted demographic audience then the
next time an audience sees your brand
they're going to be able to associate
with it it's not going to be foreign to
them or the first time they've ever seen
it you really want them to recall hey I
know that brand I've seen that brand
before okay that's kind of the reaction
you want to get from a brand awareness
hey that's a cool looking logo or man
that product looked interesting now I'm
going to take the next step so that's
what brand awareness really needs to do
it needs to create that recall for that
for your audience okay so let's take a
look now at reach so with reach reach
ensures that our advertisement is seen
by the maximum number of people within
our target audience and budget so with
we're really trying to reach or get her
ad out there to as many people as
possible given who we're trying to
target and given the amount of money we
have to spend so it helps to target a
smaller audience to visit your website
watch your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to considerations
so we talked about awareness we talked
about brand awareness and reach with
consideration we have you know people
who are willing to take that next step
okay so if we're targeting a specific
demographic and we're looking at
consideration we really want them to do
something with our app we don't want
them just recall it or see it for the
first time we want them to take that
next step and so with consideration we
have traffic so if we have an ad you
know the least we want somebody to do
who's seen our brand before is at least
click on our ad okay so we want people
to you know click on our ad and go to
our website really that's on a goal of
consideration is hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before let me click
on this and see what they have to offer
so this might involve them listening to
a podcast or reading an article or being
introduced to an app so really you're
setting the stage for further down the
funnel by further introducing than with
something that's on your website so you
really want them to take that next baby
step the next baby step is clicking on
the ad going to your side and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or service so
Facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past behavior okay so that's a
great thing about Facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience
okay so engagement so we're talking
about traffic we're going to talk about
engagement so these types of ads are
useful when we want users to engage more
with our ad for example we can you know
really have an advertisement or post
that will allow people to like it
can respond or even take advantage of an
offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within Facebook about
our at or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement an engagement
audience for your Facebook page that can
be used for future advertising campaigns
so we're really getting people to take
that next step and what's that next step
if they don't go to our website they can
like what we have to say and then we can
have app installs so that's another
option to us for consideration so app
installs are great if we want to send
users to an app store for example so
they can download our app so for really
really pushing an app that we just
developed then an app install could be a
good opportunity under consideration to
tile that user take the next step and
download your app so that at a later
stage they can go and interact with the
app we have video views - video views
are are good advertisements when you're
promoting your product or service and
you really want a high number of views
so remember early on we were talking
about the types of ads available on
Facebook we talked about video views how
they get 10 to 30% more engagement well
that's really what we want videos to do
under consideration we really want
people to understand what we're trying
to do and really engage with our product
and so they could turn around and like
it they could turn around and push it
out to their friends so video you we
know is high engaging with an audience
and so having a video allows you to
really allow that video to potentially
go viral
okay so video views help users engage it
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements
okay so highly engaging all you know
interactive allows people to you know
really really take that next step with
your product or service by really
getting to know what you're all about
okay then we have lead generation so
lead generation is interesting because
remember those leads that
mentioned and the more time of the type
of ads that Facebook has to offer
well lead ads or you know if you have a
lead generation type bad really what you
could do is you can just collect the
information and so really somebody's
interest in your product or service
right away then you can generate a lead
ad and allow them to say hey you know
what I'm interested I'm gonna sign up
for your newsletter or yes I'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your CRM
so for example salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point
so that's consideration so we have a lot
of good options available to us under
consideration you know we could drive
traffic video views app installs just
regular engagement you know and then we
got legion so we got a lot of
opportunities for consideration if
you're really trying to target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so
targets people who are more likely to
respond through messenger so facebook
Messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with Facebook and
so with Facebook messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or can be a rep
who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
capstone of kids
duration because it takes into account
one of Facebook's most popular features
which is messenger it allows you as an
advertiser to use that feature to engage
with your targeted audience directly
let's turn our attention to the last
objective which is conversion so under
conversions we have conversions product
catalog sales and store visits so for
conversions really this is the end of
the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so ads related to the objective
of conversions really aims to increase
you know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means signups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have your your product product
catalog sales so for product catalog
sales these could be ads to help promote
your ecommerce store or other products
in your store portfolio you know so
think of Amazon think about all the
products they have on their website you
know they are probably likely going to
choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so it really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns when you're really
looking for sales and then we have store
visits and so store visits really help
direct traffic to your location and
really helps deliver ads based on your
users current location okay so if we
really want to get somebody to the store
if you have a brick-and-mortar store for
example then you can use store visits as
your objective under conversions to
really drive traffic to that location so
that's what store visits are we really
want people to you know take that next
step get to your store
and check out your store and purchase so
that's what store visits are under
conversions objective so within each of
these advertisement objectives we can
create split tests also known as a/b
testing and the reason why we call it a
B testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a with one
promotion and then we have B which is
the same audience same everything except
a different promotion so you're really
changing one variable when you do a
split test and so that's available to
Facebook just like any other type of
advertising let's say you do you know
search advertising on Google split
testings available say you do email
marketing split testing is available
with subject clients Facebook's no
different it allows split testing or
allows you to use two versions of the
same ad I'm able to change one of those
parameters so you can see really what
ads performs best that's the whole idea
behind a split test okay so if it's the
original sales sale of 25% off then
hey so be it you know it works because
you tested it against another variation
and then the great thing about testing
it never ends so if 25% off works over
say $2,000 off then you try something
else to see if that will increase sales
that's the whole idea behind testing is
you only want to you always want to see
what works okay so really what it comes
down to is it can be really gonna be a
promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the
call-to-action you know a different
color on the call-to-action it can be
anything you want to test as long as
you're able to you know figure out what
works and then apply what works so you
can continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a be
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test
then really once you identify that
element and you test it and you know
what wins then you can move on other
things to figure out what else works so
if you test it the promotion they can go
on to the CTA so you could test things
like colors and call to actions and
imaging and messaging and positioning
and you could play around with your
target audience in test a segment of a
target on ends against another so
there's lots of things you could test
when you a/b test the most important
thing to note though when you a be test
is you always want to keep in mind what
metric you want to measure the test up
against so some of the metrics you could
use our click-through rate which is CTR
cost per click CPC you can use
conversion rate also known as CR or just
clicks the whole idea is when you do a
test and you're testing a promotional
offer or you're testing even the
call-to-action you need to measure that
up against a metric so that metric is
what's going to determine the winner and
so it doesn't have to be overly
complicated it can be as simple as
testing you know one call to action
against another and determining which
one gets more clicks and if one gets
more clicks than the other then hey you
know you have a winner okay let's go
through the steps of creating a new
campaign on Facebook using Facebook's
ads manager so you're gonna log in to
facebook.com slash ads manager and
you're just gonna click on the create
new campaign button and when you do that
you're gonna see a screen that looks
just like this and you're gonna go
through a series of steps so as we
presented earlier the first step is
always choosing your objective so we
have awareness consideration and
conversion so recall that awareness was
getting your brand out there to people
who never seen your brand or product or
service before so it's a matter of
trying to reach as many people as you
can to get your brand out there and so
you have brand awareness or you have
reach remember one is controlled one is
uncontrolled
okay so Reach is a little bit more
because you could set your budget okay
and you can control your budget a little
bit better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having Facebook
plop it in front of the ad in front of
as many people as possible
with reach you are trying to maximize
how many people you show your ad to but
it is a little bit more controlled
against the budget okay either way
choose an awareness is going to set the
objective of trying to maximize your
exposure for your brand your product or
your service okay if somebody has
already seen your brand or somebody's
already familiar with your product or
your services then you may want to
choose the objective of consideration
and so these are people who again are
already familiar who you want to take
that next step
remember Facebook is an environment we
are targeting a specific audience so
you're targeting people you know have
likely seen your brand product or
service so you want them take that next
step that's what you want them to do
okay so here under consideration we have
traffic engagement app installs video
views legion or messages all of these
choices are getting somebody to do
something for you for example app
installs you want them to install your
app or engagement you want them to like
or share your post video views watching
your video or messaging you want them to
interact with you via Facebook's
messenger feature so all of these are
interactions of some sort where
somebody's taking that next step they've
seen your brand they're interested but
you they're not ready quite ready to
purchase yet okay so that's what
consideration is then you have
conversion this is people in the funnel
who you know or think you know want to
convert and when I say think you know
meaning you know you're really targeting
people who you've targeted before who
maybe is purchased from you before or is
exactly the type of audience you're
looking to purchase case you have
conversions you have catalog sales and
you
store traffic meaning driving foot
traffic to a store so these are people
further down the funnel who you don't
necessarily want to take a smaller
action like just share your Facebook
post or provide their email address and
name okay so you want them to purchase
so these are three marketing objective
you're gonna choose from okay so we're
just gonna choose conversions for the
sake of this example and then when we go
to choose conversions remember we can
create a a be split test okay so that's
a choice you should always choose
because you always want to be testing
something okay in this case we might
want to test the app we might want to
test say the call-to-action because
we're looking for conversions so it
could be as simple as having one ad with
a buy more and the other way that says
hey check out our website so you have
that option to a/b split test and then
you have budget optimization which
basically allows you to set your budget
evenly across your different ads okay
and so what Facebook's going to do is
basically make sure that the best
performing ad is going to be seen more
often so that's budget optimization
you're maximizing your budget towards an
ad or ads that you want to be able to
have more control over in terms of
what's working and what's not working
versus not selecting this option your
ads are just gonna randomly show and
there's not gonna be any necessary
control over how much spend each ad gets
so that's the first step in creating
your campaign it's always choosing your
objective with a few options built in so
the next step in the process is ad set
okay and as you can see here before you
even get to ad set what Facebook is
prompting us to do is look at basically
how the a/b test is gonna work so here
they're explaining how an a/b split test
works okay so basically what an a/b
split test does is serve up 50/50 the
original versus
variation of the original okay so that's
more or less how an a/b split test works
and so Facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now notice we chose
conversions our objective okay so what
we're going to be required to do is put
a conversion pixel on our website so
that Facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want people
to do is purchase and so what we need to
do then is add a Facebook pixel to our
website so that Facebook can actually
track how many people purchase from your
campaign so this is very important and
so if you're driving traffic to your
website and you want them to convert
then you need to make sure all the
tracking is in place so the next step in
setting up your ads is setting up an
offer so if you have an offer that you
want to provide go ahead and select on
because the default is set to OFF okay
what you can do is you can associate it
with your particular company page on
Facebook and then you're gonna create
your offer so I'm gonna put my offer
title I'm gonna put a little bit more
details in there I can put an end date
when the offer expires and a specific
time so based on what you put this is
what people is going to see with the ad
and here you have the redemption section
where you can have people redeem the
offer online or online and in-store so
if it's online you need to provide
Facebook with the URL where people can
go and redeem that promotion that offer
and then you have a chance an
opportunity to add a particular code so
you don't necessarily have to have a
code with your offer it could be a
one-time code or it can be a unique code
okay or unique codes okay and then you
have an advanced option here and this
advanced option is pretty important
because if you're setting up an offer
and you only want a specific number of
people to see that offer then and you
don't want them to share that offer then
what you could do is
The Share Option so that way people
won't be able to share the promotion
with friends or family or whatnot now
they can still copy and paste a link of
the offer but they won't be able to
easily do it with the share option and
here you can put some terms and
conditions so that's the offer okay and
it's pretty intuitive in the wizard my
recommendation is you should always put
out an offer to get people to you know
again your objective is to get people to
convert so an offer always helps
incentivize conversions okay here we
have our variable because we're testing
we're split testing okay so here we're
we're choosing what we want to split
test so if we choose creative basically
what we're doing is we're telling
Facebook we want to test our creative or
at and so now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna select the audience and so
we could choose a custom audience a
look-alike or all so here you can see we
have a look-alike and it look like
basically is basically what Facebook
does is they're trying to find people
who are very similar to your customers
okay so that's who you want to target
people who look like your customers on
Facebook okay so you could choose a
look-alike audience you could choose a
custom audience if you already have one
so we're gonna create a new custom
audience here and basically what we want
them to do is website traffic and we're
just going to call it website traffic
and basically it's going to be all
website visitors okay so we're going to
create this audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell Facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where those
visitors is going to come from so we
want to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to United States
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas you can even
upload locations in bulk so if you have
a specific set of locations you can
upload that after you choose your
location you're then going to choose
your age so here you have if you look
all the way down to 13 years of age and
then your range goes all the way up to
65 years of age then we have our gender
we can choose both men and women or just
man in just women and then we can target
a specific language if we want to target
Spanish people or people who speak
Spanish then we can choose Spanish
notice we can add multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if I click
suggestions then for example Facebook's
gonna offer us up some suggestions so if
we want to target people who have an
interest in foreign language or charity
and causes or mindfulness or it could be
specific job titles okay so we can get
really detailed with our targeting we
also have connections so who do want to
target so are these people who like our
page who are friends of people who like
our page we can also exclude people who
like our page okay so remember your
advertising is tied to a Facebook page
however you could still drive that
traffic to your website but what
Facebook does is once you connect your
ad or your campaign to a Facebook page
then they have an idea of the profile
then they have an idea of what type of
community you have on Facebook okay so
that
really helps them offer you more
detailed targeting in the form of
connections so when we're done we could
save the audience so I'm just going to
name it English in Spanish click Save
okay now I have my audience saved and
the important thing here is that this
audience is saved we can use it at a
later date or if we're setting up a new
campaign we can pull from the same
audience under usually saved audience so
if I just type in English in Spanish
you'll see my audience here ok and we
can always edit it if we need to okay so
next is the placements section so here
placements is where we want to show our
ads ok so we want to be able to place
our ads in the proper placement and so
what Facebook does is they actually
recommend you do an auto placement and
so Facebook will based on your audience
show your ad in different spots or
different placements throughout Facebook
based on the people you're trying to
target the audience ok so in this case
we're targeting both Spanish and English
ok and we're targeting 13 is 65 year
olds who live in the United States and
so what Facebook's going to do then
because we have automatic placements set
up is they're going to be able to place
our ads based on our target audience so
this is an option I always recommend you
do and Facebook recommends as well if
you're specific about where you want
your ad to be placed then you can just
select edit placements and notice when
you select edit placements here you have
different options not only on Facebook
but on Instagram as well okay and
Facebook's Network and in facebook
Messenger so you have all these
different options available to you if
you really want your your ad place in a
specific position so here if I just
scroll over here I can see what it looks
like in a feed in-stream video I can
scroll down to Instagram that's what it
looks like in a feed on Instagram Tam
you have Instagram stories if I want to
go and
on facebook messenger then I have some
options here in messenger inbox or
sponsored messages okay so you have a
lot of options available under edit
placements meaning picking your
placements specifically but again I
recommend as does Facebook just go with
the recommended placements for now
unless you're really clear you really
understand how Facebook works and where
these placements are actually going to
be but remember if you choose edit
placements in place in any specific
position let's just say on message your
inbox remember your audience may not be
there so going with the automatic
placements you know is a way for
Facebook to help you get your ad in
front of the right audience here the
next section delivery optimization okay
how much of our ads are optimized and
delivered so remember we chose
conversions here so we're going to
optimize our ads for conversions so what
Facebook's going to do is take into
account each conversion that each ad is
getting and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery based on how
many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so you
can put a cost control in place so you
have an average cost per purchase okay
so Facebook will aim to get the most
purchases and spend your entire budget
okay if you put in an average cost per
purchase so for example if I'm selling
t-shirts I may not want my average cost
per purchase to be $20 because I'm not
gonna make any money so I'm probably
going to choose maybe 2 3 4 even as high
as $5 on a cost per purchase because I
want to make sure I'm not spending a lot
of money just to get a purchase so you
have that option available to you to put
in as a cost control and here we have a
conversion window and so what this
conversion window is going to do is
is you know help Facebook optimize your
ads a little bit better based on the
number of conversions that happen in
this window okay so you have some other
options in here you want to do standard
delivery ad scheduling you can run your
ads on a schedule or you can run them
all the time okay and then moving down
to the next option in our ad set is we
have split test and split test budget
and schedule so we have the opportunity
to put a budget in place for ads okay
and we can schedule the the a B tests to
start running immediately if we want to
or we can have the a/b test run at a
specific date and we can have it run for
a specific period of time so this goes
all the way back to the first option
where we chose a/b split test on step
one so we have a series of options
available to us for the split test okay
once we have all our options in place
okay we're going to click continue and
then the final step is actually setting
up our ads okay so what we're going to
do is we're going to name our ad in this
case a day okay it's going to be tied to
a Facebook page it's going to be tied to
an Instagram account and then we could
choose the format of our ad so remember
we have a lot of different options
available to us on Facebook we have two
carousel which allows us to have
multiple image just scrolling
horizontally we can have that single
image ad we can have a video we can have
a collection of images so we have a lot
of options available to us and then what
we could do is we can link up our ad to
a specific page okay now before we do
that we want to be able to upload our
images okay so we're going to manually
choose images videos and links okay and
then we're going to add some text to
support that image okay and so when we
add text in for ad we have
option of setting up a headline actually
it's not an option it's actually
mandatory the description is actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention and you want to add a
description to support that headline so
I always recommend putting in a
description and then once you do that
you're gonna add your destination URL
and then you're gonna be able to preview
your ad okay so if we have an image here
okay we can just say hey this come check
out our new product and so as I add this
information I'll be able to view it on
the right side okay so looks like
Facebook at this point it's not able to
view the image but normally you're able
to see a preview in this case it's on
the mobile newsfeed so if we drop down
we can see desktop right column okay so
we need to really choose our images so
we're going to change an image here
let's see if I can choose another image
okay I'm going to choose an image here
and so now I can see the image now I can
see the headline and then I can see what
it looks like just by changing the
placement okay so if I want to choose
Facebook stories whoops that's not
available if I go to for example instant
articles okay here I can see what my ad
looks like on instant articles so was it
available on certain placements because
of the type of ad we chose but the point
being when you set up your ad you choose
your image and you write your headline
and put your destination URL in then
you'll be able to preview it on certain
placements depending on what type of ad
you chose okay once you're sitting once
you're set up and remember we're setting
up a be testing so that was ad one now
we want to test the second ad or the
variation and so basically what we want
to do is choose the same type of format
then what we want to do is pick a
variation what is that variation going
to be it could be made
just a different headline okay or it
could be a different URL you need to
decide what it is you're going to test
once you decide what you test you're
going to add that to variation B once
you add that the variation B then you
have both ads setup once you confirm
Facebook is going to confirm for you
whether the ads meet their criteria okay
and if it doesn't in this case you can
see we have some errors then we need to
go back and fix them so I'm gonna go
back and choose single image ad okay so
now I could just choose my one image so
I can browse a library of images I
already have now here's my single image
ad I'm going to add some text in there a
website URL a headline
remember you wanted to be catchy okay
you can change the call-to-action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose so
remember we chose a B test so we're
going to setup both ads at a and add B
okay and when we do that again we can
have Facebook review it once they review
it we they can confirm these you can see
we still have some errors on a day so
let's go ahead and fix that I'm gonna
choose single image because that's what
add B is I'm gonna browse my library
maybe I'll just test a different image
I'm gonna click continue and so
basically keep everything the same what
I'll test is maybe the image so you have
to go into an a/b test knowing what it
is you want to test ahead of time okay
once you do that you're going to go
ahead and continue to add B and then
once you do that here let's go ahead and
fix this error here the link field so
let's just go ahead and put a link in
there continue to be once I confirm then
I have two ads ready to go on specific
placements or excuse me automatic
placements and this option is that's the
option we chose and basically the ads
are set to optimization against
conversions we have a set budget and
we're gonna be able to then once our ads
go live is look at some reports to see
how they're performing so that's the
steps and setting up a campaign on
Facebook you're choosing your objective
okay then you're setting up your ad set
okay and then once you set up your ad
set with your target audience then
you're actually going through the
motions in this case we set up two ads
because we chose a be testing okay and
if you didn't choose a/b testing then
you would just choose to set up the
first ad and once you do that you
confirm and voila your campaign is setup
based on these three steps
okay so let's review with some do's and
don'ts of Facebook
so we mentioned the types of AD that
Facebook has we mentioned how to set up
a Facebook ad itself and choosing the
right objectives and so some of the do's
involved are what's just what I
mentioned we always want to do a/b
testing on our ads whether that's again
just changing out the color we're
changing out an image you always want to
do a/b testing because Facebook has you
know carousel ads and because they have
you know ads that can rotate and you can
use even video with your ads you always
want to take advantage of what's given
to you and so Facebook allows you to do
it do it so if you have the opportunity
to have video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definitely do
is use engaging videos and imagery so
you don't necessarily have to use a
static ad or image ad you can use the
carousel for example with a presentation
mode where you could show multiple
images to really showcase your product
and service so with all the advertising
that you do you always want to align
your messaging so use a message that
will stay with the audience okay so use
something that's going to be able to
trigger remember it depends on the
funnel and where you're at so if your
awareness or consideration or conversion
that has to align with your messaging so
if you're you know targeting ads you
know when you want people to convert
then your message is going to be as such
you're going to talk to people as if you
want them to convert as if they're ready
to convert and you want to keep your
message consistent and simple so
remember the ads are available to you
and you have so many different features
available to you within those ads but
that doesn't mean you got to convolute
it with messaging so keep your message
cyst consistent and simple if it's brand
awareness you know definitely keep your
message simple so that people can
understand exactly what it is your
product or service is all about then you
want to alter your rage so that the ads
are shown to the pro
audience okay so you always want to keep
in mind who you're trying to target okay
so you don't want to target somebody
who's not in your demographic so alter
your reach so that the ads are shown to
the appropriate audience remember you
have you know reach available to you and
reach allows you to really pick and
choose exactly who you're targeting to
and how often remember you want to reach
as many people as possible but you don't
want to reach the wrong people
okay some of the don'ts to stay some
things you want to stay away from is you
don't want to put all your money on one
campaign so you want to separate out
your budget allocate your budget across
different campaigns and I would even
take that a step further and you know
put different types of ads in different
campaigns just to see what works so
again it depends on where you're at in
the funnel if it's just brand awareness
okay maybe create a campaign for that if
it's consideration create a campaign for
that because in consideration you might
have lead ads in there I say with the
awareness campaign you may just have a
single image ad hey just to introduce
your product or somebody with a simple
message so you want to you know
definitely think about how you want to
separate out your campaigns but don't be
afraid to separate your campaigns by the
type of ads don't put too much
information in the ads remember keep it
consistent and keep it simple that's the
best thing I could say and remember a
lot of these ads are image based so
images tell a thousand words they tell a
thousand stories a video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video but
if you're using an image let the image
tell the story okay don't forget to
proofread your ads I can't stress that
enough
remember if you're an awareness campaign
this is the first time somebody's seen
your product or service so you
definitely want to get the messaging not
only correct meaning consistent and
simple but grammatically correct you
don't want to be so active on your
Facebook page so you know when I say
being don't be so active on your
Facebook page really it depends on where
you're at you're trying to introduce a
product or service so that doesn't mean
you need to go out and tell everybody to
start buying your product remember these
people may not even know who you are
what products and service you offer so
you want to be able to approach your
audience on your Facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
Facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts you
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising okay so I want to
thank you for attending today's session
on Facebook ads for more information
please visit simply learn calm thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified
click here